lo que es importante que reconozcamos
ahora mismo es que estamos en un punto
de inflexión en el curso de la historia
de los derechos sexuales y reproductivos
y una de las cosas que queremos que sea
bien visible en el día de hoy es que le
estamos demandando a todos las personas
que están en el poder en el gobierno
incluyendo a la administración del
presidente martín que tomen todo tipo de
acción necesaria para continuar
proveyendo y optando nos la oportunidad
nosotros que proveemos servicios de
salud a continuar el acceso seguro y
legal al aborto en los eeuu es bien
importante que las personas me entiendan
y esto es una carrera a largo plazo que
tenemos que continuar el momento y que
tenemos que lanzarnos a la boleta de
votación porque ahí es donde va a
comenzar el cambio real